[موسيقى]
ما الذي تقصده بحياه مهدده هل هناك
تهديدات هل هناك مؤشرات على شيء
الاشخاص الذين حاولوا اغتيالي يتولون الان
مناصب في السلطه ثلاثه منهم سيكررون
المحاوله مجددا لانهم يخشون اذا فزت في
الانتخابات فساخدعهم للمسائله ولهذا السبب
سيحاولون اغتيال مجددا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هناك نحو 100 قضيه مرفوعه ضدي وهذه
القضايا تشمل مزاعم التحريض والتجديف
والارهاب وحتى قضايا قتل حيث اتهموني بقتل
شخص كل هذه القضايا وراءها دوافع سياسيه
لابعاد عن سباق الانتخابات
اتهموني بالارهاب بينما كنت جالسا في
منزلي وعندما حذرت المحاكم بسبب القضايا
التي حضرها عدد كبير من انصاري تهموني
بقضايا ارهاب اخرى والجميع يعرف تماما
انني خلال 50 عاما لم اخرق القانون ابدا
عندما تصل هذه القضيه الى المحكمه سيجدون
ان الشخص الوحيد الذي التزم بالاجراءات
القانونيه الخاصه بصندوق الهدايا هو انا
[موسيقى]